on est en direct sur ses visites
allez c'est parti musique j'ai mes
petites manches longues
c'est ce qu'ils avaient demandé regardez
écoutez j'en étais toi tendance dans
cette es tu vois voilà voilà bah tant
pis dire pardon pour la soirée blanche
au québec
la fin d'année approche il a assuré que
le baccalauréat sera maintenu une forme
un peu qu'ils feront et je pense que
c'est nécessaire mais pour le bowling
on n'en sait strictement rien à voir le
passé en ligne en ligne rien apparemment
serait plus facile un frère elle
baccalauréat mon frère je vais ramener
de gabat agrégé baba de mathémat la
mention très bien faire mais moi ils
veulent remplacer pour le kiff nous
occupons des khallouf quoi et nous ont
pris pour des jambons vous faire tu
crois c'est tranquille chez moi mon
frère je vais mettre tous l effet
commencé j'ai passé le bac
tous les frais que je connais mon cas
pas dire la marque
ouais mais on va vous rendre on se fait
en ce moment je veux dire la vérité on
s'en fout il ya plus de csa est plein
le csa il est confirmé que tu crois le
csa actuellement mon frère qu'ils ont
pris les 3 millions d'euros que j'aurais
donné ils sont frères dans un hôtel avec
piscine frère avec tous les membres du
csa en train de kent en train de cliff
et mon frère il disait ne sais quoi on
est confiné mon frère ils sont communs
en train de danser du compte même
regarde ça on peut tout dire les
carrefours où sont eux c'est un 8 à 8
un lidl pour j'adore cette ville
les berruyères championnes de basket oui
mais bing pâques mais dans le panier
paniers à trois points alors non pas
dans la raquette 30 secondes dans la
raquette attention attention on suit
mais qu'est ce tu fais dans la vie pour
aller voter à bordeaux le 20 ou donc
c'était bien avant le confinement total
donc voilà pour la veille à bordeaux et
quand j'ai su que j'avais lu tpe
mais hier fn diani oui
je me bats je reste chez moi et ben
barre toi tu arrives à dimitri la
question est pertinente est intéressante
et c'est rare qu'il y ait des questions
comme ça alors des téléspectateurs mais
des chroniqueurs jamais jamais jamais
jamais donc maudit mitri je te le dis
aujourd'hui je suis en mesure de tenir
qu'à 80 12 % avant j'étais 90 avant le
commandant à 92% un même acte ils vont
en vérité même on va pas se mentir à
pratiquement 100 % à moins que la chaîne
ferme parce que voilà je peux pas savoir
ainsi la freine les geeks pour l'instant
la chaîne se porte bien je serai sûr
c'est vite à la rentrée est ce que ça te
fait plaisir pour eux un bien un bravo
si vous voulez faire un coup de vis
vraiment un petit coup comme ça à des
potes voile et des copines c'est très
simple vous leur envoyez un nouveau
numéro si vous avez un nouveau numéro
vous leur envoyez votre nouveau numéro
genre avec un nouveau nom c'est à dire
vous mettez par exemple jean michel
maire si vous dire moi je me fais passer
pour l'ambitionnait j'envoie jean michel
maire avec mon nouveau numéro je mets
juste
voici mon nouveau numéro jean michel
maire vous attendez tous trois semaines
la personne elle va rentrer dans son
contact jean michel maire
elle va pas savoir que c'est moi donc au
bout de trois semaines elle va recevoir
un texto
j'ai très envie de toi jean michel maire
d'ici là elle répond ben hammam à mal
ses mots c'est mon coup préféré joli
mois à l'époque j'étais un petit joueur
comme j'étais juste tellement con c'est
à dire j'ai envoyé mon nouveau numéro et
je faisais tout de suite une heure après
et j'entre à mes côtés de ces témoins
après j'ai mûri j'ai mûri j'ai dit non
il faut attendre deux trois semaines
voilà donc voilà je vous le dis j'ai
mûri et diers fm oui on dirait
vous attendez l'hélico on doit donc
actuellement la cathédrale samedi à la
cathédrale le décès des jeunes qui a été
constitué par 12 252 par utiliser que
l'évêque la de michou inquiéter
quelqu'un qui avait des méthodes peu
orthodoxes comme vous le savez et
l'année prochaine
celui qui veut être dans l'équipe faudra
que soit la du lundi au jeudi je veux
vraiment faire des choses
feuilletonnante c'est à dire des jeux
feuilletons dans les happenings
feuilletonnant donc je veux vraiment des
gens qui soient là du lundi au jeudi à
fond parce que je voulais la vérité pour
moi une émission c'est pas je viens
lundi mardi après je suis plus là dans
les animations que ce soit dans les
autres talk tout le monde est là tous
les jours c'est pas la fête s'est pas
non plus et pas te mettre ces pages peut
devenir lundis mercredis et puis
j'aimerais poser d'europe je me reposais
mardi vendredi
big flo je voulais te dire un jour j'ai
pris un autre numéro de téléphone et je
me suis fait passer pour toi pour
sherbrooke et me dit j'ai envoyé des sms
pour frère j'ai envoyé des messages
faisant passer pour moi tu es je suis
fière maman delphine roullet parce
qu'elle répondait pas jeudi pour qui tu
te prends djette de merde tu sais qui je
suis c'est le flou
[Musique]